what's next that's the focus of
tonight's angle
in what was perhaps the most
consequential tweet sent
since election day president trump gave
the go-ahead
for the transition you see it there and
as unpleasant and disappointing as these
past three weeks have been to so many of
us as much as we wish things were
different
this is where things stand tonight now
legal challenges continue in a number of
states serious questions about vote
counting
poll watcher access are outstanding but
unless the legal situation
changes in a dramatic and frankly and
unlikely manner joe biden will be
inaugurated
on january 20th now to say this
does not mean i don't think that this
election
was rife with problems and potential
fraud
and to say this does not constitute
being a sellout to the conservative
populist movement that i've been
fighting for for i don't know 25 years
and it does not mean that i disagree at
all with the president's right and
obligation to pursue
all legitimate legal challenges to this
outcome
to say this constitutes living in
reality
and if i offered you a false reality if
i told you that there was an
excellent phenomenal chance that the
supreme court was going to step in and
deliver a victory to president trump
i'd be lying to you now you've known me
for a long time now and
you know me long enough to know that i
will not lie to you or simply tell you
what you want to hear
but what i will tell you tonight is that
even
amidst an election loss there is an
enormous amount
for us to be hopeful about even
optimistic
and how things are handled going forward
is going to have a huge impact on the
republicans ability
to stop biden's most egregious moves and
thus
these next moves are critical to the
future of the country
and thanks to president trump we have
seen the amazing results that are
possible
with his america first agenda
middle-income
blue-collar workers saw unprecedented
wage gains
the middle east historic peace deals
nobody thought was possible
of course we saw china finally put back
on its heels on trade
and because of the hard work and
talented people
trump brought into his administration
during the pandemic
he kept our economy going after a brief
shutdown
and with operation warp speed he
marshaled the resources
to end the scourge so what he did
from the time he was inaugurated through
now it worked
period and nearly 74 million americans
the largest number to ever turn out for
a republican president
they voted for him a more diverse
coalition than most of us
ever thought would happen like who
predicted republicans would gain
so many seats on the house all the
experts say that wasn't possible
they flipped 11 so far and on track to
unseat even more democrats
this is all because of president trump
ditto for the republican gains in state
houses
across america now today we see that
biden
what is he doing well he's picking
mostly bland
retreads to his cabinet john kerry will
be mr climate change
the globalist and long time biden flunky
tony blinken as secretary of state
and janet yellen former fed chair under
obama
heads to treasury with a few liberals
dropped in at homeland security
and the un we'll get we'll get to more
of them later on
now biden's entire administration is
basically going to look like a rerun
of the series cancelled four years ago
except this time without its popular
leading man obama
now we know what they're going to do
what obama did
but it's going to be worse gutting oil
and gas jobs
open borders with no deportations
massive concessions to europe on trade
is going to kill off
so much of our manufacturing and our
jobs
a climate change deal in elimination of
tariffs
that will allow china to run the table
on everyone
and much much war more but some of this
nonsense
can be stopped if republicans hold the
senate
now that means the political capital
president trump spends from now until
january 5th
the day of the georgia runoffs should be
spent convincing the people of georgia
to hold the line now in a stunning new
survey just three weeks after the
election
we already have fifty percent six
percent of americans
who want republicans to keep the senate
it's amazing now president trump can
help deliver those victories no doubt
about it
and i expect and i hope that in the
coming days
the president will announce a series of
rallies across georgia
where he celebrates his huge number of
successes of the past four years
and explains why sending two far left
radicals to the senate
is only going to embolden the worst
instincts of the democrat party
now winning those two seats will be a
great way to embolden the republican
resistance across america
and send a very clear message that biden
and his team have zero mandate to pull
our country to the hard left
this is the time for the president to
remind all americans
that we will save this country even with
the current setback
great patriots coast-to-coast have not
given up
they do not want us to be mere puppets
of europe
and the ccp and unlike those who gather
in davos and opine about the end of
national borders
unlike those who tear down our history
and spit on law enforcement
we believe in the goodness of our people
and the righteousness of our founders
and our constitution
we believe our independence cannot be
sublimated to a global order determined
by
unaccountable bureaucrats in brussels or
in paris
the people who have to get up and earn a
living every day
they need to know that they still have
champions who believe the government
should work for them not against them
and that means we need president trump
to continue
advocating for american exceptionalism
and continue reaching out to communities
who've been lied to or poorly served for
generations
and i think that when we get into 2021
2022 we will have seen team biden
stumble from one crisis to another and
voters
oh yeah voters will start wondering when
we're going to have a president
who once again looks out for our
interests
thinking about this uh today the deep
state
schiff pelosi big tech the media
wall street they shoveled money at biden
hollywood pro
athletes who make millions in china they
all did
everything they could to destroy trump
plus then we were hit with a pandemic
that originated in china
and yet with all of that on january 21st
2020
he will still be the most important
person in american politics if he wants
to be
after all we all know biden's not going
to be the one calling his own shots
people i don't think realize what it's
going to be like
when we have more than 70 million
americans mad
at the way the government is run under
team biden
now it's true the democrats were mad too
for four years but
at least for most of that they had
incredible peace and prosperity
to enjoy addressing the irregularities
and instances of possible fraud in this
election
it probably won't be possible before
trump leaves office
but what he could do this is just as
important as jo
as georgia is appoint a presidential
commission on election reform
and this group must investigate exactly
what happened in states like
pennsylvania
and in michigan etc and offer serious
recommendations
to see that this never happens again
there is zero reason why every state in
america can't be like florida or texas
and call this thing an election night
this cannot turn out to be a permanent
find the votes you need game to bury
republicans no way
but believe me i think the democrats are
hoping they're probably betting
that president trump spends the next six
weeks just railing on about
how the election was rigged and so forth
but i don't think there's a need for him
to keep relitigating that in the court
of public opinion because a huge
percentage of americans
already believe that trump remains
the most compelling voice in american
politics
and this thanksgiving we should all be
incredibly grateful for his service to
our country
and his sacrifices for this country
the fact of the matter is no one else at
least not right now can bring the energy
draw the crowds and attract new voters
like latinos and african-americans as he
did
and i personally cannot wait to see what
president trump does next
and by the way you're always welcome
here
and that's the angle